We were told to eat healthy, and to pay attention to our consumption of calories during the day
But do you stop how it can be a calorie form?
For example this amount of 200 calories of apples
On the other hand, if we take 200 kilos of heat from cheese, they are never the same size
And add 200 calories of wine to the group for a wonderful blend of wine and cheese
Thus you will have 3 different forms of 200 calories
Now compare that wine with beer and jam and you'll have 3 different festive evenings for your stomach
Or what about the eggs you eat in breakfast?
Compare them with the 200 calories of the cereal you eat the next day, or even some oatmeal
Thus they must be different
But if you compare it with the sausage sandwich with eggs for breakfast, you will get less
cauliflower? You will be surprised at how much you can eat before it reaches 200 calories
Not to mention that this stuff is packed with food and an important source of fiber
Pizza piece? Less than a slice if it does not have a pepperoni
What about the traditional Big Mac sandwich? Try the small Mac sandwich with 200 prices
Since calories are simply power units, you can charge 217 Big Mac sandwiches
Provide the car with a 35 km drive card
So wait. What is calorie?
Specifically, the calorie is the amount of energy needed, or the temperature needed to heat one gram of water one degree Celsius
We need energy to live, and we get it from food
Starches, proteins and fats are building blocks of our taste, each of which provides our bodies with a certain amount of energy
Normal humans need between 2000 and 2700 calories a day
Depending on factors such as height, weight, gender and age
Some foods, such as peanut butter, are high in calories, making them quickly supplement those needs
Or like the rich ones you ate as a snack, which is likely to contain more calories than you'd expect
And the attractive Doritos chips? Do not lie, I ate a whole bag
Unlike celery, which contains a few calories, it gives you a lot to bite
Or islands
Not a lot of Harshi granules
If you eat salad to reduce calories, beware of creamy sauces
Especially French
Coffee itself has few calories
You can drink a lot before you reach 200 calories
But the moment of adding sugar and cream will double those calories quickly
And to go for specialty drinks such as frozen moccasins
You may be surprised by the amount left
But that does not necessarily mean that it is a little calorie thing
It is more healthy or better for you
Take, for example, 200 calories of cola against 200 calories of milk
Although the prices of cola are less per liter
But do not forget the benefits of rich milk and healthy fats
Or like baking asparagus against white bread
Yes, whole grain bread contains higher prices for the slice, but also contains plenty of food and fiber
So, calculating calories is not the goal
But think that what you are dealing with is what will make a difference
In the end, all moderately and healthily
If you want more examples of 200 calories, explore the WiseGeek newsletter for their link in the explanation box
Where more food is considered
Have a question you need to answer?
Ask in comments or on facebook and twitter
And subscribe to more scientific sections weekly!